points joel embiid a season low how were  you able to hold them down  uh just as a collective effort  that's a really good team  you know obviously embiid is one of one  of the better players in this league um  you gotta mix it up you know show them a  crowd showing body different looks try  to make it tough for them and uh try to  contain the other guys points joel  embiid a season low how were you able to  hold them down  uh just as a collective effort  that's a really good team you know  obviously mb is one of one of the better  players in this league um  you got to mix it up you know show them  a crowd showing body different looks try  to make it tough for them and uh try to  contain the other guys